catherine deneuve bonsoir on vous voit
dans ce film ans en jeans et pull-over
et non plus en sa laurent comme
d'habitude en ans mère de famille
débordée qui se console d'un mari volage
avec un jeune chanteur
c'est une nouvelle expérience sur le
cinéma où c'est une ouvre une nouvelle
image pour vous écouter d'abord je pense
pas que ce soit la première fois comme
voie avec un but in au cinéma
j'étais habillée par saint-laurent -
souvent qu'on ne le dit mais je pense
que ça a beaucoup marqué sans doute
parce que ça me va bien et que j'ai
d'image là qu'on retient elle est plus
elle est plus frappante mais c'est une
image que sur la qualité absolument
d'accord et c'est une image que j'ai
choisie est une machine corner au
personnage
moi je suis pour la cohérence j'ai pas
envie de me décoiffe sétif est pas
justifiée j'ai envie de remercier
laurent si je trouve que c'est ce qu'il
ya de mieux pour le film mieux pour le
personnage mieux pour mieux pour moi
mais d'abord le film et dans dans ce
film c'est quand même toujours ce
personnage de la femme libérée de la
famille bras franchi libellé vie quand
j'ai longtemps mais je crois que c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt une femme qui a
envie d'être libre enfin une femme qui a
envie d'être libre une femme qui a envie
de tout vivre une famille j'ai envie de
tout vivre en même temps une femme qui
est à la fois a pris dans ses
contradictions de travail de d'amitié
d'amour de vie professionnelle devient
effective une femme une femme
d'aujourd'hui une femme d'aujourd'hui je
trouve riez vous choquer c'est un
portrait assez assez juste c'est une
femme qui est douloureux c'est une femme
qui est à mantes aimante qui est très
maternelle très nerveuse assez sèche
comme ça c'est comme les champions pas
le temps moi ça me convient assez jeune
qui vous ressemble un peu un petit peu
oui un petit peu
et alors vous avez vous avez dans ce
film de très bons partenaires qui vont
faire rare et vos coups de coeur oui
avancés par les seuls qui l'ont bel sont
craquants c'est le mot c'est vrai
christophe lambert et richard anconina
et ça je le connaissais je n'avais
jamais tourner avec lui mais je l'avais
vue est vraiment remarqué très fort dans
le film d'alain corneau qui fait le
choix des armes
christophe gelé découvert en tournant
avec lui avant de voir quinze ans n'est
pas encore sorti à ce moment là ils sont
deux acteurs oui mais étonnant et
maintenant encore plus s'ils sont très
amies dans la vie sont de 2 à 4,6 depuis
longtemps il ya une un courant de
sympathie qui existe réellement en être
sûrs qu'il passe très très bien à
l'écran via fine donc signé elie
chouraqui
oui avec qui vous aviez à petit sur le
gaz bossi qui fut ma petite fille dans
le film qui est la saison étonnante donc
toute une famille à découvrir dans
paroles et musique film qui sort dont
demain